LOUIS GRAY: Good afternoon.
Louis Gray here from Google
Developers Live in Mountain
View, Googleplex.
I want to talk here
with JJ Behrens.
He's a developer advocate
for YouTube APIs.
Welcome, JJ.
JJ BEHRENS: Thanks.
Nice to see you, Louis.
LOUIS GRAY: Good to see you.
I love this new studio.
We're just kicking off today.
JJ BEHRENS: It's pretty
exciting.
LOUIS GRAY: So you're the first
one to talk about this.
We're getting prepped for Google
I/O next week, running
through our tutorials.
And you went ahead and did a
talk on Ruby on Rails, and
specifically how it applied
to YouTube and education.
JJ BEHRENS: That's right.
LOUIS GRAY: So what I want to
do is go ahead and have a
quick conversation with you and
explain, how does Ruby on
Rails involve with YouTube
and education?
Maybe you can walk through
that for us.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, so I talked
about this a little bit in the
talk itself.
It's a little bit strange
talking about
Ruby on Rails at Google.
Because if you look at our
jobs postings, oftentimes
they'll mention Java
or C++ or Python.
But not very often will
they mention Ruby.
And definitely, I don't
think I've ever seen
them mention Rails.
And then, if you look at Ruby
on Rails talks, oftentimes
they're talking about Heroku
and Amazon EC2.
But they don't spend as
much time talking
about Google APIs.
And since I kind of straddle
the fence--
I do a little bit of Python, a
little bit of Ruby on Rails--
I wanted to change that.
I know that our YouTube APIs
work perfectly well in Ruby.
And so I wanted to show
people how it's done.
LOUIS GRAY: Now, one of the
questions I know a lot of
people run into with YouTube,
because they have a certain
expectation of what that
site represents--
people look at it as for
entertainment or for news.
What does it have to
do with education?
Because you took a very specific
approach to this.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, well,
strangely enough, YouTube
actually can be used for things
other than just cats.
LOUIS GRAY: Although we
like the cat videos.
JJ BEHRENS: Not that
cats aren't--
yeah, we like the cats.
The cats are important.
Those are a staple
of our business.
But education's important.
I actually have six kids.
And so education is really
important to me and especially
scalable education.
I want good, high-quality,
And I think that video makes
that possible, scalable.
You have a great lecture.
You get it on video.
And you know you can reuse
it over and over again.
One of my favorite examples are
the lectures by the MIT
guys, Structure and
Interpretation of Computer Programs.
These are like a staple of
good computer science
from the MIT guys.
And I watched those videos
all the way through.
And I feel like I got just a
little bit of an MIT education
out of those.
LOUIS GRAY: And that's
something--
I don't know if you can
put it on the resume--
but it sounds like a good place
to find out [INAUDIBLE]
[? education ?] and expand
your [? world ?]
knowledge.
What do you think about TDD?
When we went through
your talk, you
talked a lot about TDD.
And I know people are
curious about this.
Does Google use it?
How does it get involved?
JJ BEHRENS: So test-driven
development is a way of
developing software in which
you write the test first.
And then you watch it fail.
And then you try to write
the code so that it
makes the test pass.
And then, once you're passing,
then you refactor the code so
that it works better.
And Google's a big place.
And we have a lot
of engineers.
We have the saying that, you
get two Googlers in a room,
and you'll have three
opinions.
And so of course, not all of
them are going to agree on one
particular way to develop
software.
But testing at Google is
incredibly important.
And so a lot of people do use
test-driven development.
And even those people who
don't use test-driven
development find that writing
comprehensive tests is an
incredibly important
part of their job.
And so I wanted to talk about
how to do test-driven
development with web APIs.
Because that's hard.
If you've ever used the YouTube
API, the responses
that it gives you are
very complex.
They're large.
And so it's hard to figure
out, what response
am I going to get?
I don't know ahead of time
until I actually try it.
And so a part of the talk
is showing people
how to get the response.
So that they can play with it
and then integrate it into
their tests.
So that they can do test-driven
development with
realistic responses from YouTube
without actually
requiring a network connection
in order to run your tests,
LOUIS GRAY: Test-driven
development sounds a lot like
Google's approach to launching
and iterating.
Yeah, you get it out the door,
and you continue to improve.
For me, at least, when
I took something
resembling computer science--
I didn't get the kind of BS
degree that most of us have
around here--
but my tests always
seemed to fail.
And I couldn't ever
understand.
You would look at creating
content and creating code.
And writing it on a sheet of
paper didn't make sense.
It was always about putting it
in the machine, and trying and
trying, and seeing where
did it break.
Is that something that you see
fits in with the corporate
culture in terms of testing and
iterating and accepting
something that needs some
iteration going forward?
JJ BEHRENS: Well, it's funny
that you mention that your
tests always fail because I
have the opposite problem.
I like to spend tons of
time writing code.
And then I code review it.
And it's perfectly polished.
All my tests pass.
And then the first time I give
it to a user, it blows up in
front of me.
And so definitely, test-driven
development is a way so that--
the programmer who's writing
the software codes
it to be one way.
And the tests verify that
it behaves that way.
But then when you need to change
it, the tests protect
you from breaking software
that used to work.
And when you get code that's as
large as it is at Google,
that becomes really important.
We have just a couple engineers
around here.
And so we have to be able
to work together.
And so we have to be able to
extend software written by
someone else without
breaking it.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
Now, when you were talking, you
mentioned version 3 of the
YouTube APIs.
What can you tell us
about version 3?
Why is it significant?
I know a lot of times you look
at iterations and they have
point releases.
What's going on in version 3
that made this the one you
want to talk about?
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, well, you're
always trying to get me to
leak information.
That's how we make these
videos sell, isn't it?
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
JJ BEHRENS: So currently, the
YouTube API is at version 2.1.
And version 2.x has been
out for a long time.
But we have some interesting
talks going on at Google I/O.
I will say that much.
And another thing that's kind of
interesting is that if you
look at a lot of the newer
Google APIs, such as the
Google+ APIs, they have this
very, very nice client API.
What do you call that?
A driver, whatever--
client library that's really
nice and that the client
library automatically updates
itself to match the API so
that the client libraries
don't go out of date.
And so this is a problem that
we've had in the YouTube world
for a long time.
And that sometimes we'll make
changes in our API, and the
REST API will be very
well-documented, very, very
functional, super,
super stable.
But the client libraries
sometimes lag a little bit
behind, especially since we
have to support so many
programming languages.
So this problem kind of
goes away with the
newer client libraries.
They will automatically adjust
themselves to whatever the API
currently is.
And so I really look forward
to a future with up-to-date
client libraries.
LOUIS GRAY: [? Now, Jerek ?]
actually had a question.
You were getting close
to this issue.
We were talking about dynamic
languages a little bit ago.
So [? Jerek ?] was saying, he's
told the time save with
dynamic languages such as Ruby
can be invested in better test
coverages, which leads
to better software.
Do you think that that's true?
Or do developers usually take
that time savings and just go
watch more YouTube videos?
JJ BEHRENS: Well, it's tough
because I try to do a little
bit of both.
I do want to watch those
YouTube videos, but--
yeah, this is a way of thinking
that's been popular
in the programming world
for a while.
I think it was Bruce Eckel.
I forget.
The guy who wrote Thinking
in Java, who first
pointed this out.
And I think that this idea is
popular in the Python world,
but it's even more popular in
the Ruby on Rails world.
The Ruby on Rails world--
of all the programming
communities out there, they
seem to be the most devoted
to testing and test-driven
development.
And so Ruby on Rails
lets you program
software incredibly quickly.
And yet it could turn to mush
pretty quickly if you don't
keep a hold of it.
And so using test-driven
development with a very, very
strong test suite is how you
keep the wheels from coming
off the cart that's flying
down the road
at 70 miles an hour.
LOUIS GRAY: And is that why you
use a debugger to code how
to do this?
JJ BEHRENS: So the debugging
trick is
kind of a funny trick.
And I did this even before I was
a Ruby on Rails developer.
When you're coding in a very
dynamic programming language,
there's so much stuff that's
going on at runtime, you just
can't statically analyze the
code in order to figure out
what's going on.
So much stuff is being injected
and metaclasses, and
all kinds of funky stuff--
metaprogramming happening
at runtime.
And so sometimes the only way,
the only source of truth, is
the actual running program.
And so I discovered years ago
that the best way to write
software is fire up the program,
get it going, and
then dump yourself into the
debugger in the middle of the
running program.
And then look around.
Play around with what
variables you have.
And the debuggers for Python
and Ruby aren't like the
debuggers for C, where
it's just a way
to inspect the state.
Rather, they're shells.
So you could write
code in them.
And I use this trick to write
lots of code in the debugger,
get it all working,
and then copy and
paste it into my program.
Great trick.
LOUIS GRAY: Now, I'm going to
get you back to version 3.
See, I was trying to get you
to leak stuff before.
But if I continue to ask you,
you'll keep leaking.
And so we were talking about
client libraries before.
What do the client libraries
have to do with version 3 of
the YouTube API?
JJ BEHRENS: So the big key
here is we're going to be
talking about version
3 coming out.
And it's based on the new
API infrastructure.
And Google has this new API
infrastructure that's used by
some of the newer Google APIs.
And because we now have this
common API infrastructure, we
have things like consolidated
developer keys.
But this new API infrastructure
is also what
makes it possible for all
the APIs at Google
to behave the same.
We'd like it if we could get to
the point where a developer
knows how to develop
with Google APIs.
And when he needs to use
a new API, it just
kind of makes sense.
Because it works like
everything else.
And he doesn't need a
new client library
for every new API.
He could just use his existing
client library because that
client library should just
automatically know how to work
with that API.
And that's the goal.
It's slowly taking
place at Google.
Some of the products have
already moved over, and I
think we're going to see
a lot more of that.
LOUIS GRAY: Now,
[? C Truman ?]
from LA was having a question,
fired it over the moderator.
Beyond education, what are
some other app ideas that
could be implemented
using YouTube APIs
with Ruby on Rails?
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, that's
a great question.
So it's funny.
When I first did this talk,
it's like I had this goal.
I wanted to talk about education
because I wanted to
spend a little while devoted
to education.
And I wanted to talk about
Ruby on Rails.
And I was like, how the heck
do I do these two things at
the same time?
Because I only have a fixed
amount of time to write some
software, give some talks.
How do I do these things
at the same time?
So I was like, whatever.
I'll just do both of them
at the same time.
But the fact of the matter is,
you could write educational
apps in Python.
And you could write
non-educational
apps in Ruby on Rails.
It doesn't matter.
By having the one talk, I
address the two different
things at the same time.
But mix and match.
There's lots of different ways
to do education and lots of
different programming
languages.
And there's lots of different
things that you could do with
Ruby on Rails other
than education.
LOUIS GRAY: I'm going to ask
you a different question.
Now, you've been at YouTube
for about a year.
How would you say YouTube is
a little bit different,
possibly, than the
rest of Google?
What's really unique about being
a developer there and a
developer here?
JJ BEHRENS: It's funny.
It's a subtle thing.
We like to say that it's a
ghetto in the good way.
My grandmother came from
a Russian ghetto.
And it was a nice place for
her, according to her.
She says, everyone
knew each other.
Everyone liked each other.
YouTube, that's definitely
the case.
We are a little bit
of a niche.
My key card does still
work in all the
different places in Google.
And that's good because
I like to eat at all
the different cafes.
We do have a lot of the same--
we have pretty much all
the same process.
We use all the same tools.
But there's a little bit
of a different focus.
I watch a couple videos
a day at Google.
I don't know if it's as
well-accepted in other parts
of Google to just chill
out for 20 minutes
and watch some YouTube.
But it's definitely the case--
LOUIS GRAY: You can chill out,
watch some YouTube videos, and
say, no, I'm working.
In case the boss comes by, you
say, I'm troubleshooting.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, yeah, that's
definitely like--
although the normal trick of
being a software engineer and
saying, my code's compiling,
that does not work at YouTube.
Because most of our software
is written in Python.
So there's no compiling.
LOUIS GRAY: That's too bad.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, really.
So.
LOUIS GRAY: Well, anything else
we should tell everybody
before we head off and start
working to get ready for I/O?
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, jeez.
Is it time to go to sleep yet?
I mean, I'm exhausted.
LOUIS GRAY: I know.
There's time for that.
That's the July 4
week, I believe.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, is that right?
Yeah, this Google
I/O stuff, wow.
It's a busy time.
I'm super excited about it.
I know we have a lot of great
talks coming up at Google I/O.
A lot of great YouTube talks
because I've been watching all
the rehearsals.
And I know that we're leaking as
many things as we possibly
can to get people excited
about it.
LOUIS GRAY: So there's lots
of news coming up.
I'm sure we don't have time
to cover all of it.
JJ BEHRENS: I know.
I know.
But I'm super excited.
I'm excited to see that
[? keynote ?]
because even I don't know
what's going to happen.
LOUIS GRAY: I won't tell you.
All right.
Well, thanks a lot, JJ.
JJ BEHRENS: Thanks
a lot, Louis.
LOUIS GRAY: Thanks for spending
time with us.
I appreciate it.
JJ BEHRENS: Very nice.
LOUIS GRAY: Thanks.